Traduttore: Massimo Garzotto
Revisore: Manuela Mancinelli
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Buonasera a tutti.
Quella che stiamo vivendo oggi tutti
è un'esperienza.
Lo è per voi e lo è soprattutto per noi
che siamo da questa parte del palco,
e aveva ragione Steve stamattina:
è bello vedervi tutti in mutande.
Per chi è da questa parte,
l'idea è quella, in qualche modo,
di lasciare il segno,
di comunicare qualcosa,
di coinvolgervi,
di coinvolgere i vostri sensi,
di regalare appunto un'esperienza.
Ma come fare?
Occorre capire cosa ci stimola
nel ricordare un momento,
un po' come quando si era bambini.
Beh, da bambini è difficile ascoltare
è più facile ricordando
- è più facile ricordare
una cosa con il vissuto
e noi adulti non siamo tanto diversi,
infatti l'esperienza
è la migliore forma di apprendimento.
Io e il mio team realizziamo
installazioni immersive, interattive
che hanno il compito di regalare
un momento speciale alle persone,
che hanno il compito di essere ricordate
quando le persone tornano a casa.
E nel fare questo ci siamo accorti
che ci sono tre tipologie
di situazioni chiave che caratterizzano
questi momenti importanti.
Noi tentiamo di toccarle tutte
con la tecnologia.
Non è facile, perché dipende
dalla situazione, dai mezzi
che abbiamo a disposizione,
come per esempio questa presentazione.
Qui ci sono io, ci siete voi
e abbiamo questo schermo o forse no.
Cerchiamo di attrarre
con il diverso, con il difficile
ed è difficile veramente trovare cose
che ad oggi siano diverse da altre:
tutti fanno qualcosa di diverso,
tutti fanno qualcosa per essere originali
però tutto si muove troppo in fretta.
oggi, tutto è troppo veloce.
E questo dal giorno alla notte.
In verità cerchiamo scalpore,
cerchiamo di stupire:
però lo scalpore non è altro
che la rottura di un equilibrio:
è l'inaspettato in un momento di comfort.
Ma perché è così?
Perché il nostro cervello
lavora per patterns.
Interpreta tutto ciò che lo circonda,
e per questo è elastico.
È sensibile alla ripetitività del vissuto,
riconosce ciò che ha già visto
e questo da sempre
perché è primordiale;
conosco questa situazione,
per cui è tutto ok.
Quindi, ragioniamo
per connessioni emotive prevedibili:
quindi, da equilibrio c'è rottura
e questo il più delle volte
genera gioia dell'inaspettato.
Però, per la rottura,
serve qualcosa da rompere,
serve appunto l'equilibrio.
Questo, per esempio, è il ritmo visivo;
e quella è la rottura.
Quindi per noi la prima caratteristica
è appunto lo scalpore;
che però non sta in piedi,
se non c'è il tempo e il ritmo.
In studio da noi,
lavoriamo di arti visive
quindi il senso più importante,
per noi, è la vista.
Cerchiamo qualcosa di diverso,
cerchiamo una rottura;
e lo facciamo appunto
con la tecnologia,
che ci aiuta ad andare
fuori dagli schemi.
Ci aiuta con soluzioni, formule;
e la prima cosa che ci siamo chiesti è,
perché utilizzare
una superficie bianca e piatta
quando ci sono
altre forme interessanti?
Questa è una struttura
in materiale povero.
Ma immaginiamo per un attimo
che sia un prodotto da presentare,
o l'unveiling di un pezzo d'arte;
oppure ancora, un monolite di marmo.
Beh, in studio da noi
è teneramente chiamata 'Monalita'
ed è pensata come esempio
per far capire
come si possa raccontare
attraverso la forma,
perché di fatto questo
può essere, potenzialmente,
un nuovo livello di comunicazione.
Beh, immaginate gli usi:
immaginate, in un negozio,
una borsetta che comunica
con la propria pelle
i vari materiali di cui è composta
o i vari colori in cui è proposta;
ma, anche un passo indietro,
l'arredamento o ancora
qualcosa di più grande.
Noi un passo indietro l'abbiamo fatto
e abbiamo pensato
come lo schermo possa essere un limite,
perché anche la luce deve essere
incastrata all'interno di un bulbo,
perché non può essere libera
di essere disegnata sulle pareti.
Può essere questo un modo di creare
luce non convenzionale, diversa?
Beh, si può. Ed è così
che noi l'anno scorso
abbiamo pensato e brevettato VEDO.
Questo è un angolo del nostro studio,
le pareti sono bianche
e l'arredamento è bianco.
Tutto accade in tempo reale
con il soggetto.
Il sistema è simile a quello
che stiamo utilizzando oggi.
Queste sono quelle che chiamiamo
atmosfere immersive, pareti vive,
fonti di luce diverse
da quelle a cui siamo abituati.
E gli spazi cambiano,
viene rotto il limite spaziale.
E tutto questo viene fatto
con il controllo
attraverso uno smartphone,
attraverso un'App
che mi permette di cambiare le atmosfere
in base alle mie emozioni,
in base a quello che voglio vivere
in quel momento del mio ambiente.
Quindi, parliamo di ambiente pulsante,
parliamo di stimolazione dei sensi.
Non ci sono più schermi:
non è più una comunicazione
tra persone e persone,
ma è comunicazione
tra persone e ambiente.
Immaginatevi la lobby di un hotel:
entro in hotel come visitatore,
e l'ambiente intorno a me cambia
a seconda della situazione,
del tempo, dell'evento.
Oppure l'esperienza con il cibo
in un ristorante,
dove mentre mangio qualcosa
viene esaltato
attraverso le pareti che mi circondano.
E ancora musei, spazi piccoli
come imbarcazioni, yacht
fino a grandi spazi pubblici.
Sono geometrie che comunicano,
quindi perché avere il limite
di questo schermo bianco,
quando in verità
abbiamo tutto questo?
Questo è il coinvolgimento spaziale
ed è il secondo punto.
È esperienza immersiva,
è architettura che cambia pelle,
che esalta i concetti, che aumenta
i miei sensi e il mio spazio,
che comunica emozioni, fantasia.
Questo è il teatro indoor
più antico al mondo:
ma immaginatevi una visita immersiva,
immaginatevi di poter vedere
attraverso la struttura
come è concepito,
di immergervi nella struttura dell'opera,
vedere come è progettata,
tutto tramite una tecnologia
completamente nascosta.
Immaginatevi di poterla esplorare...
... con un altro tipo di comunicazione.
Un altro modo di penetrare
gli ambienti che andiamo a visitare.
Quindi non più dei chioschi che sono
più simili a tablet datati ad oggi
o mura di monitor
che urlano gli sconti.
La tecnologia ad oggi può essere
molto di più in questo senso,
può enfatizzare il valore delle cose...
...rivelando informazioni,
può intrattenere in modo funzionale,
può esaltarne la maestosità.
Può simularne il passato,
esponendo le sue stesse cicatrici.
Ma tutto questo non ha valore
senza un terzo elemento,
probabilmente il più importante:
l'emozione.
Noi e i nostri sensi
siamo al centro di tutto questo,
tutto il resto è un'alchimia dei mezzi
che raggiunge l'apice solo se noi,
come maestri d'orchestra,
stiamo attenti a bilanciarli tra di loro
e che ci esprimiamo come esprimiamo
le emozioni attraverso i sensi.
Quindi il mezzo deve essere
coerente con i contenuti.
Beh, come qua, al TEDx,
che racchiude e impacchetta
gli interventi e le idee
sotto un unico titolo,
Planting the seeds,
che non è altro che piantare il seme..
.. di ciò che nel futuro
diventerà grande...
... e parte integrante
di ciò che siamo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)